[Music]
my name is monique fisher and i'm the
senior photograph conservator here at
the northeast document conservation
center
so today i'm going to go through with
you
how to conserve a nearly 100 year old
photograph
the photograph is a panoramic format
and these usually are taken for groups
at conferences
here we see a boy's camp
the biggest problem is that it's tightly
rolled and you can't really
access the information
i've created a humidification chamber
and
the first thing we need to do is unroll
it to do any other
types of treatment to it
once i feel it gets a little limp then i
start to
unroll it
the next part of the treatment is
surface cleaning
there's going to be surface dirt on
these photographs they've been sitting
in an attic or basement
[Music]
on the back we are using some dry
cleaning techniques
weights that we use are actually steel
i-beams
cut to size and put on there and they're
actually used in construction
the white wedge there that you see is a
cosmetic sponge actually
and the surface is nice and soft
in addition to the cosmetic sponge there
are things
like a polyvinyl eraser to get more in
ground dirt to remove that
[Music]
the powder that you see here is really
not powder it's
shredded a polyvinyl eraser and
again it's a more gentle way of cleaning
the surface dirt
on the back of a photograph
[Music]
those dry cleaning techniques that i was
using on the back of the photograph
could be problematic to the emulsion
here's some cotton swabs with water and
alcohol
to remove some of the surface dirt there
the cloth that is used is holly tex it's
a woven polyester
and it's a non-stick surface
the most thing you need to be careful
about is again the emulsion it can get
wet
if the emulsion has been compromised
because it's been
exposed to light or been sitting in
attic for years
the emulsion can get very soft and lose
the image
at the same time
prior to mending i'm wet tearing the
japanese paper
i want soft edges along the paper
i want to make the mend as invisible as
possible
we are straining the wheat starch paste
that we use
[Music]
everything that we do in this profession
is supposed to be reversible so we use
wheat starch paste we don't use any
kinds of tapes we don't use archival
tapes
[Music]
so
i take the brush paste out the japanese
paper
on a piece of paper that helps absorb it
and then
put the japanese paper on the back of
the tear to mend it
[Music]
and even just a little bit of paste and
you know small pieces of japanese paper
can really strengthen a tear
it needs to be flattened putting it
kind of in a sandwich between holly tex
blotting paper and then some weights on
it
so it can dry and flatten
with tears you try your best to put it
together
perfectly but because this is an old
object
there are going to be losses in the
emulsion or within the image
and here we have an in painting
technique
the paint brushes are actually fine
point brushes that are used to paint
doll's faces
[Music]
i like using the gambling conservation
colors because you can use
isopropanol to wet up the color
i'll put some color on my brush paint it
out on the blotting paper there
and then when i think the color is you
know good enough
i will then paint the object
and so you blend it all in so that your
eye when you're looking at the panorama
doesn't go
right to the tear
so once these techniques are done we
need to
flatten it overall so that you can
handle it
the photograph the paper support has a
memory
so you want to be able to reduce that
memory
by humidifying it and putting it under
pressure
so you can add humidification but you're
not getting the object wet you
don't want to get the object or the
photograph wet
it will start to feel limp and then we
put it under
light pressure usually it stays
underweight for about a week
[Music]
it's with a thick blotting paper that
helps absorb the humidity
because if you put the photograph or the
gelatin right against
the blotting paper it will stick and
then you're in trouble
so once a photograph has been flattened
we want to create a preservation housing
and the preservation housing in this
case
is we're creating a polyester l sleeve
but if you have a unique format like
this panorama
you're going to have to make it yourself
so i'm putting the two pieces of
polyester together
welding it on the short side and the
long side
[Music]
and once that housing is complete
i trim it so it looks nice and then put
the photograph in there
and then return it this way to the
client who can easily
handle it and look for their loved one
and the panorama
[Music]
you